how did you enjoy your theme song that
was a great song I'm surprised that you
have the music rights to use it one of
the many things that you don't
acknowledge that I've done was deal with
music rights is that what you did on the
show I asked you for years did you you
did stuff with music rights you do
realize that while it's a great song and
it's great for this uh operation I don't
know what we're calling this radio show
it's uh limiting the distribution of
said show you're going to want to
distribute the show in certain ways but
you've got that Rush theme song that's
Li is this limit it in any way Mr Gru no
we're good don't know this is serious
this is serious radio you have to leave
your options open for future listen
Jordan not with this show I don't okay
let me promise
you there's no way anyone's gonna say
how do I get this on
vinyl I must have a
reproduction they're not they don't know
they're not going to want this it's
going to live on serious radio where
we're allowed to play any Rush song you
want what are the other ones you like oh
well I uh there Rush has many different
periods uh what's the one that I used to
sort of try and sing Limelight that was
do go yeah living on a lighted stage
approaches the living on a lighted
[Music]
[Applause]
stage was that kind of is that a Getty
lead you think that is not what I expect
expected this show to be you singing in
a falsetto tone uh was not how I
accurate that was an accurate Getty Lee
it was not
inaccurate that means it was accurate in
a roundabout way I I argue that there is
once again on the stage isn't it
something like that right that's his
General register yeah yeah how pleasing
to the ear look for you rush fans out
there um no offense but Jordan I'm glad
you're a big fan of theirs and through
my fame you actually got to know the
band a little bit didn't you I did yes I
did so maybe a thank you yeah thank you
you uh I've I've been able to benefit in
certain ways from your own celebrity
which I feel is deserved because you
have to remember that your celebrity is
a product of the work of the many people
that are here in this very room and
Beyond I don't see it that way we have
worked I do not see it that way while
the finances don't necessarily reflect
that the truth of the matter is this is
not a Onan operation this was a group
effort well first of all I'm not saying
it was a Onan operation I'm just saying
that uh once a millennia a figure comes
along um a
Mozart um a uh a socres and they soes
what' you say Socrates in the original
ancient Greek
pronunciation what are you
talking about no one knows how the
ancient Greeks pronounce that I know how
it's pronounced now everyone listening
knows how it's pronounced raes Socrates
wait a minute how do you know how the
ancient Greek spoke ancient Greek
influenced other languages we can trace
the lineage back by studying other
ancient languages Socrates aristotele
this is no I don't think you're right
about any of this first of all um
congratulations on inventing a time
machine may I see it can I can I get
inside your time machine understand
there are people that study the past you
don't need to travel back to the past
know how they pronounced we don't know
how they pronounced socres you don't
know how they pronounce Socrates I know
how they pronounce don't know how they
pronounce Socrates I just said how they
pronounce Socrates that's not true you
no one can possibly know how they
pronounced it there's no photographic
evidence who a photograph doesn't
represent how something is pronounced
anyway I'm telling you there are that
was a little trick to see if you were
paying attention I mean when I say phono
I'm I'm talking about the uh audio there
are linguist comes from the Latin lingua
which means the tongue also in Italian
can I tell you something I know you're I
know where you're taking this I know
where you're taking this which is oral
sex and I think it's disgusting and no
one wants to hear you go on and on about
tongues and linguist and you know going
down and all that kind of it's garbage
it's just garbage that's not the way
anyone should be pleasured it's
disgusting it's not described in the Old
Testament and I won't have it so
Socrates sorry what was that I played
Google Google's uh pronunciation of socc
thank you Edwardo when it say that was
an incorrect pronunciation wait you're
arguing with Google Now I'm not arguing
with Google I'm not arguing because I
know my position my position is it's
Socrates and that's as that's as far as
I'll go with it but can I ask you
something your interpretation does not
change reality you don't have a PhD in
doctorate comes from the Latin do
or in the ecclesiastical pronunciation
do which means to teach which in fact is
what we're doing here we are teaching
you just say no and you say it with
great Authority and then we're all
supposed to say yeah yeah I guess so
then I look but then I look into your
past and I realize you're
some you're just some guy you're just a
guy you're just a guy I don't disagree
I'm a guy who know how do you say do and
doer and Socrates and
aristotelis how do you say spaghetti
spaghetti it means little
strings there's spago which means a
string there's spaghetto which is a
little string and then there's the
plural spaghetti can I just point out to
people this is our first episode but to
people listening to the Conan and Jordan
show when I when you when I'm not
speaking and Jordan is just know that
I'm holding my head I'm just my head is
down and I'm holding it and I'm sad and
I'm sad and that's just something for
you to know as you're driving along
listening to this well Jordan I have to
say you and I in the past have you can
people watch these on YouTube all the
time and on our various sites they watch
the adventures we've had where you shoot
off your mouth about your expertise on
say where the Karate Kid sequel was shot
and then I prove you to be wrong and
you've been proven wrong about several
things some of the things maybe in in
Italy you were incorrect about certain
word usages oh is that true yeah you
were you actually lectured me about how
no one I wanted to have a red wine with
my pizza remember that and you said no
one has red wine with their Pizza you're
supposed to have a beer and then I asked
the waiter who served me MH in Naples
what do you have with your pizza and he
said wine yeah and I saw a little part
of you die yeah no one is a euphemism I
did not mean no human being in Italy
would ever drink red wine with pizza I
just meant it's generally ined well what
a coincidence that the one guy who did
happened to be a waiter at the pizza
resta he worked in the food industry of
course he had he may have different
habits than the average Diner he's an
I'm not responsible for his preferences
only fact as I have observed that such
fact I'm not an expert on this
particular waiter's eating preferences
I'm chewing my mic cord right
now go on what else was I incorrect
about you've got a list no I don't have
a list of you you're looking at a piece
of paper tapping it you looking down
when you come up with a new subject go
ahead what's the next on the list you
are Nixon in 74 you are cornered you
know it's over uh you're sweating um and
you're babbling on television uh I
resigned today effective
immediately don't hate your enemies when
you hate them they
win um I don't know this Ser demographic
but I do know this they are not familiar
with the voice of Richard Nixon okay
well that's I think condescending
because I always assume that uh I am not
even familiar with the voice of Richard
Nixon I'm a 50-year-old man oh so you
don't know about a president of the
United States I know there was a
president named Richard Nixon who lived
pretty much in your lifetime yeah okay
you don't know about you don't know
anything about that guy know you know
that socrates's name 2,000 3,000 years
ago was the
Socrates and that's how pronoun that has
relevance today go ahead do do some more
impressions of historical figures from
the middle of the century what did
Eisenhower sound today December 7th
1941 a day that will live an in for me
who was that Truman that's Franklin
Roosevelt you son of a you know
unbelievable so you know Socrates but
you don't know about uh who was
president when Pearl Harbor was attacked
you have a particular interest in
presidential history let's not pretend
that your average listener shares that
interest with you you're right I should
assume that they all share your interest
which is that Socrates uh all of us have
been saying it wrong all these times I'm
not going to stand by as you
mispronounce the names of incredible
figures from ancient history hey Jordan
how annoying was it for Socrates he was
probably walking around and people were
like hey Socrates I got a question he
was like it's
Socrates oh take it easy Socrates I said
it's
Socrates man you are one uptight
philosopher
uh how do you say PL please say it plate
oh you son of a
so okay all right okay so Goofy's dog is
named plate I'm not familiar with
Goofy's dog that's not my specialty I
I'm I have a cursory knowledge of Disney
I didn't know like isn't goofy is a dog
I know he had another dog you know
what's sick a dog has a dog for a pet
don't you think that's disgusting
I think it's one of the sickest things
about Disney what dog keeps another dog
as a pet that's
wrong and you know what I think it's
terrible and I you know who would agree
with me Socrates and plate they never
figured out why goofy was able to speak
wasn't exuse me it's
goofy oh man torpedo a mid
ships the explosion could be seen for
Miles I hit Che right where the
Torpedoes are stored oh my
God